Debra I voiced the Golden State Warriors
he joins us here on the show Tim do you
have a a technique for preserving your
voice well I think when I get colds and
right now I'm doing getting crushed by
allergies I tend to go with hot tea with
honey and then if you're if you're
really sick then that it's kind of gross
but it does work is that that neti pot
oh no no I'm telling you that's your
friend before you on the air you could
get that one of those three and you're
good for a few hours okay the the neti
pot for people that that aren't familiar
with it is basically a tea pot full with
water that you stick into one nostril
you turn your head but put your head
between your legs basically and the
water comes out the other nostril and
you're basically gagging the entire time
like it's not it's not a pleasant
experience Tim no it's not it's not but
it does work it does work it's got me
through a few broadcasts this year it
really did so when you're doing these
games can you tell when Golden State is
taking a night off well you know I think
this is the weirdest year the for that
of this run they're on this is magical
you know run of the franchise but
they're you know they've been through it
all they've done it all they're so
they're a record for most wins they've
won two championships they lost one
where they kind of you know let slip
through their fingers they got that one
back they got a ring for Kevin Durant so
I think this year they've had trouble
with that laser type focus and so at
times they look like they're not totally
in sync and they're not and and so but
yeah you can usually the indicator early
is turnovers and it's not just turning
the ball over it's the way they turn it
over you know a pass for someone who is
not there goes sailing out about the you
know the pass thrown to someone who
wasn't looking or he tried to off the
dribble throw a bounce pass that's gonna
thread the needle by three defenders to
get to a guy on the other side you know
the one that has almost like a point
zero zero zero one chance of getting
through as
when you see those kind of things that's
that's an indicator that that they're
not totally locked in do you think the
words have played well in two games this
series I thought they played well and
for a good chunk of last night
offensively they played I thought
they're their best game in a while days
they really were opportunistic they read
what the defense gave them if they
needed to set a screen they said screen
if they could slip the screen they
slipped it if they you know they move
the ball they had twenty eight assists
that's always a good sign if they get
anything above 25 assists that means
they're playing pretty good basketball
on that end but I don't think they play
great yet they haven't had that one you
know game this year where they're
totally you know in in lockstep and and
the other teams have something to do
with that too this year I think the
level last year at this time you know
the lawyer said it entered the finals
twelve Annelle Cleveland was twelve and
one well this year has been a different
year for both teams so it's it's it's
not been the the quick path and a lot of
blowouts and a route to the finals
the end of Game one when jr. starts to
dribble that ball out do you start to
question whether you knew what the score
was did you question whether you were
aware of the situation I questioned jr.
said he my sandy the league said they
were happy to play like that in the
finals yeah he he throws everybody off
when he does that I mean that's that's
you totally don't expect first of all
you don't expect him to get the rebound
that's number one and then he dribbles
out to half-court you're good look at
the score what what the heck is he doing
I mean it's like it was just insane and
you know I had I've never seen anything
like that
I mean Derek Harper I remember Derek
Harper dribbling out a tied game with
Lakers the years ago it wasn't an NBA
Finals game though wasn't it what it was
in the Western Conference playoffs but
it was you know it was a tie game and
he's standing at half-court dribbled it
out thinking that they had the lead but
I'd never seen anything like that you
see ID perfect that split second you
don't when you see him do that it
totally throws you for like what the
heck is going on here and a very very
strange play I'll think we'll ever see
that again
[ __ ] of timber or the voice the Gold's
day war is joining us here Dan Patrick
show Tim you've seen far more Golden
State games than I have but that game in
Game one that looked to me like the
first time in a long time that the
Warriors got beat like not that they
sometimes they beat themselves but that
looked to me like Cleveland LeBron James
legitimately beat them that's why I was
such a big blown opportunity to me
because that was the best I think
Cleveland could possibly play you know I
thought yeah I thought they played
really well and and and and even leaving
last night you know for a long start to
the game they were within striking
distance you know they kept it
manageable for a long stretch last night
they're there they're a lot better than
people were saying going into this
series but but yeah Game one I thought
that was a great chance and those are
hard to get back you know the Warriors
had Game four gets Houston where they
were up 10 in the fourth quarter up 12
in the fourth quarter and let it get
away and when you let a game like that
get away in a seven-game series that
means you have to be the other team kind
of five times you beat them once and let
it go
now you got to be in for more time so it
those are tough to bounce back from
especially in the way it happened you
know for for Cleveland I thought it was
I thought emotionally they did a great
job last night of kind of coming back
and not letting that you know affect
their game that's the thing though Tim
like I've heard this this kind of
narrative that the Cavaliers are better
than we thought I just I don't think
they are
I just think LeBron James is so great
he's making everybody else look better I
mean you you've done all four of these
finals that they've played together
can you dispute that this is the worst
Cavaliers team of the four I mean I
guess you go back to the first one with
all the injuries but on paper this is
not even close the worst Cavs team of
those four isn't it well I think I think
the numbers show this the worst
defensive team of the four but without
question this year they just didn't
never got maybe silly they flipped the
roster midseason but they never got
there their defense totally to where
they wanted and yeah and and because you
could make the case that the guys around
them you know they're not as seasons
they're they're younger they're not
they're not as talented or battle-tested
as the teams that came before but you
know the
take it my analogy step further LeBron
still on the Cavaliers so to me they're
still better than what people say
because he's playing so well you know he
can he can will them to to the victory I
mean he's just having this incredible
run but yeah I think they're better than
what people have said I don't think
they're as good as some of the teams
we've seen just simply because you know
on the defensive side of the ball they
just did not have a good year when you
watch the Brawn of all the things he
does what stands out to you the most is
his court knowledge his instincts he
knows angles he knows when to go he has
that that sense of I'm going to you know
come over here with the ball and and get
my screen here because I know if they
react the way I think they're gonna
react I can make that pass to you be an
easier pass and and he just he just has
this knowledge that very few players
have you know I've done on the Warriors
side you know the two guys I think are
kind of like that our dream on green and
Andre Iguodala and and and and LeBron is
he's up there with anybody in the game
and in his instincts and his knowledge
on how to play the game and why things
work basketball for Timur Roy boys the
Golden State Warriors joining us here
Dan Patrick show what's going on with
Iguodala I just think it's it's
something that you know it's a bone
Bruce that got in there and and for
whatever reason he can't get it right he
can't get it to the point where he can
he can move you know side to side and do
the things he wants to do and and I just
just think it's a it's a bad you know
must have hit him in a bad spot you know
I'm not I'm not really a medical guy but
it you know if Andre could play I know
he would play he's just he's you know he
loves especially at this this point he
loves this stage he loves you know the
challenge of trying to you know as best
he can slow down you know the one of the
greatest players ever to play in the
game so whatever it is isn't that it's
something that he just can't get it to
the point where he feels he can get out
there and and and give it a go and I
bad form because this is usually when
when a guy like Andre usually hundreds
of kind of player that when the Warriors
need him to score he scores when the
Warriors need him to be a distributor he
gets seven assess when he needs to play
defense he has a game where you look at
his line it's not very good and then he
looked at his plus/minus and he's like a
plus 25 or plus 20 or plus 18 so I know
that this is this is bothering him right
now two years ago we saw a 73 win Golden
State team blow a 3-1 lead in the finals
is there anything that can happen in
this series up to zip that you think
could make it go against Golden State
well I do
again you have Laurent go back to LeBron
I think you know he could and we saw
last year in the series that that you
know if the Cavaliers have one of those
nights where they're knocking down
threes I think the worst could easily
lose a game or two because you know
that's the one thing they the Cleveland
depends a lot on the three and if they
get there their offensive game moving
and going one or two nights they're good
they're going to be very tough to stop
and so yeah I could easily see the
Warriors losing a couple couple games in
this series but I like your chances
because unlike the team they had a
couple of years ago they're reasonably
healthy was exception of Andre and
because this step wasn't healthy and
then also let's face it they've got you
know Kevin Durant now and so there are
many possessions where things are going
right and he gets the ball in about
seven seconds on the clock and he gets
that he gets that mid-range shot off and
he covers up for a lot of a lot of
mistakes and a lot of you know
situations where you're not supposed to
get a good shot before I let you go
you've got a good vantage point usually
they're from radio row what's the best
parts of being in that position what can
you see in here that that other people
can't that helps you out
well most places weren't you know unlike
the the national broadcast most place in
the NBA radio is off the floor now we're
halfway up the building that's
disrespectful I mean that's just
disrespect
they write up today right no the so so
we don't have that kind of website
access we once have but the one thing
that that is cool especially from the
Warriors perspective is I get to do it
at Oracle and at Oracle it's it's it's
such a unique place the salad just comes
right off the ceiling comes beaming back
down to the floor and you're right in
the middle of all that and from sitting
where I'm sitting and watching Steph
Curry do his you know his magic with the
ball sometimes and getting that overhead
view of it it's fantastic because you
know he just he just puts on a display
of ball-handling that leads into the
ridiculous shots that he makes that no
other man on the planet would even take
and then no other man the planet would
even make he's just he's an amazing
player but you know what it's got to be
aa square there this is my 23rd year
where the Warriors my 29th and the
league and I wouldn't really change a
moment of it it's it's a it's an honor
and a privilege to work in this league
are you gonna miss Oracle when it's gone
of course of course yeah that's him Tim
let's the come on like that place is a
dump like just-just-just but in the
place next when they demo that place
just demo the a stadium with it OCO just
demo at all like have you have you been
here for playoff games
oh yeah many ok so you know you know you
know it's like in there I mean it's just
it's that type of feeling it's the
feeling people get out when they go out
in the concourse after the game and
people are dancing and they've got music
going and it's just it's just it's just
the atmosphere and the whole crowd
involvement that sums up Oracle the
great thing about Oracle is that you
know that the crowd the crowded Oracle
doesn't need the scoreboard to tell when
it's a big play yeah they they know when
it's a key moment they know when the
Warriors need to get moving and they
react and and it's it's a it's a great
place I'm gonna miss it terribly when we
leave but the new place in San Francisco
the Chase Center is gonna be fantastic
and it's going to be world-class and we
just can't wait to get in there you're
gonna
when you're in your nice cozy office
there in San Francisco a comfortable
chair air-conditioned yeah let me tell
you about where Radio ranks here now
apparently low is what I'm guessing
actually actually the the the Warriors
are very nice they let me work out of my
home office so that's that's even even
even better so damn always good to talk
to you man enjoy the next couple of
games and thanks for joining me
always a pleasure sir take care that's
Tim Wright the voice of the Golden State
Warriors joining us here Dan Patrick
sure for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]